le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la jeunesse
réunionnaise c'est l'avenir de la
réunion
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des jeunes réunionnais est donc un enjeu
majeur
les jeunes doivent renforcer leur
autonomie et acquérir les compétences
nécessaires pour accéder à un emploi ou
à une solution d'insertion pérenne et
parfois pour des jeunes en difficulté il
est essentiel de leur redonner confiance
en eux et en leurs capacités
alors comment déclencher l envie de
réussir chez les jeunes comment les
aider à faire les bons choix pour leur
avenir
on en parle maintenant dans léa sociale
les jeunes manquent de confiance en eux
et d'accompagnement humain leur montrer
l'exemple
leur apprendre à côté d'un savoir faire
un savoir-être avec une estime de soi
sont devenus essentiels pour leur
épanouissement
ils sont l'avenir de la réunion c'est
sur ce raisonnement que le conseil
général propose aux jeunes d'être
soutenus et accompagnés par un parent
dans le cadre du plan ambition jeunesse
pour soutenir cette action destinée et a
tiré à la fois les jeunes et les futurs
parrains le conseil général a fait le
choix de lui donner un parent
d'envergure
un exemple pour les jeunes une des
personnalités préférées des français
tant pour ses compétences sportives que
pour sa personnalité et son charisme
yannick noah les jeunes un peu ça c'est
l'avenir et donc c'est un petit peu à
nous les anciens de leur montrer la voie
de les motiver surtout est motivée par
des conseils forcément aussi par une
présence j'ai pour objectif de passer
plus de temps à la réunion on va venir
notamment faire nos répétitions pour la
prochaine tournée
notre prochaine tournée en métropole et
on va répéter à la réunion 7 à chaque
fois que j'ai la possibilité je viens la
réunion et la voilà cette belle
opportunité pour moi je vais pouvoir
être sur place et c'est une belle
occasion pour moi je suis très content
et même très touchés comme est sollicité
justement pour ce projet ans un très bon
projet et je suis très content et fier
d'être d'être le parent à voilà et ses
deux contacts et rentrer en contact avec
les jeunes leur parler discuter de nos
différentes expériences qui est
important c'est de les écouter
individuellement pouvoir savoir qui sont
à savoir qu'ils sachent qui je suis on
est l'occasion de se rencontrer
plusieurs fois parce qu'il s'agit pas
tout d'un coup devenir une fois à
discuter et puis partir ça lui bonne
chance à bientôt
je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait un suivi
je crois vraiment 1,7 à ce travail de
proximité très très souvent les enfants
en difficulté ou des jeunes en
difficulté ou des jeunes qui sont en
demande pas forcément difficulté mais on
demande ont besoin d'un suivi longelin
parfois d'être épaulé encourager mais
cet encouragement il doit être suivi
c'est quelque chose qui doit être à long
terme je crois pas au bout on va faire
un coup comme ça ça donne un peu
d'énergie et puis ça retombe très vite
comme un soufflé je crois qu'il ya une
il faut qu'ils s'installent une vraie
relation
et puis après les énergies baisse se
partager s'additionnent et voilà la fin
je me sentirai quelque part responsable
et puis selon ces responsables parce que
leur parent attendre à de bas qu'ils
assurent quoi voilà c'est je peux
répondre à cette question que d'une
manière assez général mais à la fin je
sais pour avoir été entraîneur de
joueurs et de joueuses que ya pas de
formule magique ce qui compte c'est les
coûts' écoutait que je les écoute qui
m'écoutent qu'on se fasse confiance et
qu'ensuite qu'on aille ensemble et qu'on
décide une direction qu'on y aille à
fondre l'action du parent y compris
celle de yannick noah et bénévoles
chaque parent doit jouer un rôle de
soutien de conseils de facilitateur
voire de modèle dans l'atteinte des
objectifs visés par le jeune il doit
construire une relation directe et de
confiance avec le jeune se rendre
disponible durant les différentes phases
du parcours et s'engager à être présent
lors des différents entretiens
d'évaluation programmée par le référent
la valeur ajoutée de l'action du parrain
et de consacrer aux jeunes le temps que
le professionnel du conseil général ne
peut lui accorder
dans ce cadre il définit librement avec
le jeune les modalités d'organisation de
leur relation la jeunesse réunionnaise
est un atout pour la réunion
mais elle est aussi devenue un public
vulnérable pourquoi parce que les
dispositifs existent
mais les jeunes ne sont pas toujours
informés et il n'y a pas de cohérence
vis-à-vis ces dispositifs trop répandue
trop de portes à ouvrir et ce parrainage
de 4000 jeunes est une belle opération
ou c'est jeunes parrainés auront un
interlocuteur un référent qui pourront
qui pourra les accompagner et en même
temps un parent un peu comme le grand
frère ou papa maman qui pendant une
année va porter ces jeunes en leur
disant vous pouvez nous appeler et nous
pouvons être le grand frère qui vous
manque pour vous aider vous orienter
accompagner ces jeunes et j'invite donc
tous ceux qui veulent à la réunion être
des parrains à rejoindre le conseil
général et à nous appeler la solidarité
est une des plus belles valeurs de la
réunion grâce au parrainage nous
transmettons cette valeur et
construisons avec les jeunes
la réunion de demain pour participer au
programme et devenir parent renseignez
vous sur le site du conseil général ou
directement par téléphone au 02 100 62
94 29 29
nous comptons sur vous le conseil
général de la réunion vous a présenté
lien social le conseil général aux côtés
des réunionnais